denn es ist kaum zu glauben in corona
zeiten haben millionen menschen angst um
ihre existenz kommen nur mit
soforthilfen über die runden
und genau in dieser zeit soll ein
unternehmensberater aus pinneberg
unglaubliche 7,4 millionen euro
corona helfen abgezockt haben nun sitzt
er in untersuchungshaft und genau vor
dieser jva in lübeck steht nun mein
kollege thomas knoop thomas sagt uns wie
genau ist ja bei diesen millionenbetrug
vorgegangen ja ich stehe hier vor der
justizanstalt in lübeck hier sitzt der
36 jährige aus dem landkreis pinneberg
in schleswig holstein ein
er soll versucht haben 15 millionen euro
an hilfen zu ergaunern 74 millionen euro
an bereits ausgezahlt bekomme 6
millionen konnten gerade noch gestoppt
werden
der geschäftsmann nutzte zu unrecht also
erlangte sozialversicherungs war
deutlich fällen beantragte erkner sofort
wird von kurzarbeitergeld eine
sprecherin der staatsanwaltschaft
akzeptiert dass aus
ermittlungstaktischen gründen keine
weiteren angaben gemacht werden
der beschuldigte selbst schweigt zu dem
problem konnte denn das bisher erlangte
geld jetzt sichergestellt werden
es wurde ein vermögens gegen den
hauptverdächtigen erlassen und 22
weitere personen die allerdings nicht
als tatverdächtig gelten im haus und
umfeld des mannes wurden 205 euro in bar
sichergestellt hiermit um weiter dauern
an